while I'm so thrilled to be here today
was our tips and the successful attempt
to get into the Guinness Book of World
Records for the longest feather boa
right here with New York City Ripley's
and Madame Tussauds well you know I'm a
drag queen and then all these wax
figures are done up lovely I hope to
wake up looking like them so I just
remember coming here as a kid and
enjoying all of the amazing figuring
figures because if I couldn't get to the
celebrity I can get to the next best
thing you know RuPaul has been such an
icon for the LGBTQ community so for him
even in a wax representation to be here
today this special moment for me
[Music]
I'm celebrating world Pride Month first
of all by living my life as
authentically and fabulously and out
loud as possible I hope that inspires
other peoples to also embrace every part
of who they are and get out there and
just enjoy themselves this is a ton
about celebration but it's also a
reminder that we have more things to do
in the community we need to unite
together we have to make sure that our
voices are heard you have to participate
and things like voting and just being
out there and making sure that we are
visible I just love that I've had you
know an impact on an audience on my
followers I called them fans but I also
call them friends because you know
people who have followed my career have
seen me as a baby from RuPaul's Drag
Race Season 2 to now here in Times
Square performing and working with this
great event and celebrating world pride
so it's great for us to all be united
like that so I will say back to them
ha-la-lu